the faces of 43 student teachers who
disappeared in 2014.
first they were ambushed by police
then kidnapped and handed over to cartel
gunman
in what's become one of the worst human
rights scandals in decades
the initial investigation was led by
this man former mexican attorney general
jesus murillo karam
this week he was arrested on charges of
forced disappearance torture and
obstruction of justice
the disappearance of 43 students on the
night of the 26th to the 27th of
september 2014
constituted a state crime in which
members of the guerrero anidos criminal
group and agents of various mexican
state institutions were involved in
which federal and state authorities at
the highest level were omissive and
negligent
warrants were also issued for 83 local
officials police officers and army
soldiers
vindication for family members who never
believed mirullo karan's version of
events
but with proof the moment we as parents
are sure what the attorney general is
saying is the truth only then will we
accept it
but the motive behind what happened is
still up for debate
what happened was these mexican students
they they basically commandeered a bus
and it looks like somehow they they
commandeered the wrong bus this may have
there's a theory that maybe there were
drugs on board that this somehow
belonged to one of the drug cartels and
we know unfortunately about all of these
nexuses between
the mexican state and drug cartels in a
drug war or a drug related conflict that
has led to more than a hundred thousand
disappearances
over the last 12 years in mexico
despite the arrests the remains of only
three students have been found and
identified
and whilst family members remain hopeful
investigators say that there is no
evidence to suggest the students are
still alive
shimon freeman powell sky news